dumbull when you're not really angry at  someone but you're not really happy  about them either bum by a comfortable  set of clothes usually weren't at home  away from judging eyes Lum Bing an  intense tenderness sweetness and  affection rolled into one word Papa to  eat a food item that's usually eaten  with rice on its own gig in an intense  urge to pinch something or someone  really cute it could also be an  expression of anger so use with  discretion pecan refers to people who  are hot-headed easily angered or sore  losers ooh my the feeling of being  satiated after eating a particular food  over and over again  Ghalib that feeling of being on cloud  nine usually associated with romantic  feelings thought of it a person who is  too shy to express or pursue amorous  desires leaky an irrational craving for  something often associated with pregnant  women